that the top Court in the US state of
Colorado has disqualified Donald Trump
from appearing on the presidential
primary ballot for
2024 Colorado's Supreme Court says it
barred the former president because of
the US Constitution's clause on
Insurrection it's related to his role in
the attack on the US capital on January
the 6th 2021 let's get more now from
Manuel rapo he joins us live from
Washington DC Manny so what more can you
tell us about this Colorado Supreme
Court ruling and what it
means
Good To Be With You Darren I'll read you
the majority opinion from the ruling
from that uh Colorado Supreme Court case
ruling earlier on Tuesday uh which the
term here is that Don is ineligible to
run for president that is what the
ruling says but this is uh the quote
from the opinion a majority of the Court
holds that Trump is disqualified from
holding the office of president under
section three of the 14th Amendment
otherwise known as the Insurrection
Clause the opinion goes on quote because
he is disqualified it would be a
wrongful act under the election code for
the Colorado Secretary of State to list
him as a candidate on the presidential
primary ballot so Darren how big of a
deal is this that's kind of a tricky
question to answer because the ruling
itself being it the uh Colorado Supreme
Court makes this specific to to Colorado
the uh and the Republican primary
election which is taking place on March
15 but it does have the potential to
affect former president Trump as a
candidate moving forward into the 2024
uh national election even before this
ruling was issued there was a promise by
Trump's attorneys that there would be an
appeal made immediately to the US
Supreme Court and that's the scenario
that we're got to watch out for here uh
because this does if if um if the US
Supreme Court were to affirm this ruling
then it could disqualify former
president Trump altogether from running
in 2024 but we don't want to get ahead
of ourselves there's still criteria that
needs to be uh uh met uh for this to
hold water outside of Colorado but again
the big news here is that this does have
the potential of playing out as a big
Showdown uh at the US Supreme Court yeah
Manny in terms of this ruling what sort
of response then have we had from the
Trump
campaign so not 30 minutes after the
ruling had been issued uh former
president Trump took to the social media
platform truth social I'm going to read
you part of this uh rather long rant by
former president Trump he said that
quote this is is a sad day for America
he referred to the prosecutors who are
building cases against the former
president as deranged thugs surrounding
our incompetent president crooked Joe
Biden he finishes uh that all off with
saying quote all of the rest suffer
massively from Trump derangement
syndrome TDS in other words and for
reasons unknown they hate me so in the
hours uh following that ruling by the
Colorado Supreme Court we also heard
from the so-called Maga Republicans who
taken to social media say that this is
just another quote dirty trick by
democrats who seek to uh disqualify
former president Trump from running in
2024 Trump's attorneys again have
promised to take this all the way to the
Supreme Court it will be the US Supreme
Court ultimately that has a final say on
matters of constitutionality there all
right Manel RPP live for us there in
Washington Manny thank you